Є розуміння, що до десятого дня хвороба прогресує і стан погіршується.
Доводилося дуже чекати на цей день, думати: а чим же ти закінчиш?
Чи буде у тебе пневмонія?
Якою вона буде - важка чи не важка, доведеться піти на лікарняний
чи не доведеться?
Мене звати Микита Журавльов, мені 32 роки.
Я закінчив донецький виш, нині працюю в місті Сєвєродонецьк
лікарем-терапевтом у терапевтичному відділенні.
Також я працюю інтервенційним кардіологом - оперую серця.
Але сталося так, що тепер я в основному займаюся ковідними пацієнтами
і людьми, які перехворіли на ковід.
У нас в якийсь момент лікарі почали хворіти. Одного дня я прокинувся, відчув нездужання.
Слабкість - відчуття, ніби у тебе похмілля.
Ну, думаю, буває - перепрацював. Пішов, відпрацював, ближче до вечора відчув температуру.
Зрозумів, що ось воно - прийшло. Такої слабкості у мене раніше ніколи не було.
Ми на той час вже відправили всіх лікарів реанімаційного відділення на лікарняний.
Також почали хворіти лікарі інфекційного відділення.
Якщо говорити про себе, про лікарів мого віку - ми ще могли стояти на ногах.
Якби ми тоді пішли на лікарняний, то пацієнти взагалі залишилися б тут самі.
Увечері, коли в тебе починається безсоння, коли ти лежиш, таке враження, ніби кисню не вистачає.
Але є такий диво-прилад - пульсоксиметр. У нас він зараз у всіх лікарів у кишені лежить.
Надягаєш його, дивишся - сатурація 99. І думаєш: "О, в принципі я ж і не задихаюся, мені лише здається".
Заспокоюєшся. Напевно, якби не пульсоксиметр, було б важче.
Це прилад, який показує два параметри. Перший - це частота серцевих скорочень, пульс.
І другий - сатурація, тобто насиченість крові киснем.
Усі мають вдома тонометр, термометр. Напевно, прийшов час, коли пульсоксиметр теж повинен бути в усіх.
Вам здається, що задихаєтеся - спокійно взяли, поміряли.
Приміром, у вас сатурація 93 - зателефонували своєму лікарю, порадилися, що далі робити.
Все, що вище 95-ти - норма. Все, що нижче 93-х - вимагає госпіталізації.
Якщо говорити про ковід, навіть через місяць ти знаходиш у себе віддалені симптоми, задишку.
Раніше я займався бігом. Моя звична дистанція - це десять кілометрів.
Минув місяць, і я думаю: ну, почну з кілометра. Пробіг перший кілометр - субмаксимальний пульс.
Зупинився, походив хвилин п'ять - а пульс не падає. Ну, думаю, все - добігався.
Тепер будемо довго відновлюватися. На сьогодні я повернувся, напевно,
лише до половини навантажень, які я робив до ковіда.
Хвороба ламає насамперед психологічно. Іноді у тебе немає дихальної недостатності, але тобі здається,
що ти задихаєшся, тобі здається, що щось тут дере, тут пече, ти починаєш думати: все, почалася пневмонія.
Багато пацієнтів зриваються, біжать самі на КТ, іноді роблять це достроково,
знаходять п'ять відсотків пневмонії і в істериці прибігають до нас: "У мене п'ять відсотків пневмонія, з двох сторін,
все - госпіталізуйте мене". При цьому загалом такий пацієнт має лікуватися амбулаторно.
Але психологічно він вже зломлений, з ним доводиться багато працювати, багато йому пояснювати:
"Ось, ви розумієте, вам потрібно робити те і те, і ви краще і швидше впораєтеся амбулаторно,
вам не потрібно госпіталізуватися".
У нас відділення розбите на дві частини. Перша частина - диференціальна,
це коли надходить пацієнт з пневмонією, але ми ще не знаємо - він ковід-позитивний чи ковід-негативний.
Але знаємо, що це пневмонія, і йому вже необхідно надавати допомогу.
Ми такого пацієнта госпіталізуємо, відразу робимо ПЛР-тест і починаємо лікування.
Якщо він позитивний, він відправляється на подальше лікування в інфекційне відділення.
Якщо негативний, то вважається, що він вже не заразний для оточуючих,
що йому не потрібно перебувати в ізольованому боксі.
І він продовжує лікування пневмонії в терапевтичному відділенні.
25 відсотків ураження. Під киснем десять днів лежав.
Полікується ще вдома, ще трохи відновиться - і знову до праці.
Людина готова до бою. Офіційно ми ковід не підтвердили, тобто офіційно у нього тест негативний,
але ви ж бачите історію. Звернувся до нас уже після десяти діб.
Після десятої доби виявити дуже важко. Ці люди не входять у статистику.
Якщо зробити тест на антитіла, він буде позитивним. Статистика набагато більша.
Якби під час навчання в інституті я комусь із своїх метрів сказав, що буду робити УЗД легень,\
мені б, напевно, дали запотиличник і сказали б: "Ти двієчник, йди і вчися далі.
УЗД і легені - про що ти говориш? Це взагалі несумісні речі".
Але так сталося, що особливість ковіда дозволяє використовувати цей метод - широко і дуже ефективно.
Ми буквально у вересні, відразу, як з'явилися ковідні пацієнти, почали практикувати цей метод.
Зараз ми широко його використовуємо для диференціації.
Дуже багато часу витрачається на те, щоб пояснити пацієнтові, як себе вести під час цієї хвороби.
Приміром, є така річ, як прон-позиція. Це коли потрібно лежати на животі -
мінімум годин 16 необхідно перебувати на животі.
Пацієнт, перевертаючись на спину навіть на 10-15 хвилин, може колосально погіршити свій стан.
Тобто він у тебе вранці був стабільний. Тримав сатурацію на кисні, міг перебувати в твоєму відділенні.
І ось він перевернувся на спину на 15 хвилин поговорити по телефону -
і вже треба переводити в реанімацію.
Доходить аж до того, що пацієнтам треба пояснювати: "Давайте ми вам поставимо сечовий катетер,
щоб ви не ходили в туалет?" Адже кожен крок вимагає багато сил у пацієнта, який потребує кисню.
Дехто каже: "Ні, сечовий катетер - що ви? Що ви кажете, лікарю? Який памперс? Мені 50 років, навіщо це все?"
Можливо, якби була воля лікарів, багато хто з них пацієнтів би скотчем примотував.
Тому що іноді вкрай важко пояснити пацієнтові, що це життєво необхідно: "Почуйте, почуйте".
Якщо говорити про Луганську область, ситуація тут досить цікава.
Під час першої хвилі, яка почалася в Україні навесні, то тут ковіду як такого не бачили.
У принципі ці випадки були привезені. Це пацієнти, які повернулися з Російської Федерації,
пацієнти, які повернулися з Європи. Або з окупованої території.
Місцевий шлях поширення почався вже десь у місяці вересні.
Ми щодня спостерігали, що пацієнтів дедалі більше і вони все важчі.
Такого, щоб ми комусь відмовляли, не було.
Але було таке, що доводилося госпіталізувати жінок у чоловічі палати.
У якийсь момент нам бракувало кисневих концентраторів.
Тобто керівництву доводилося зв'язуватися з лікарнями, в яких не було таких пацієнтів,
і просити їх надати кисневі концентратори. Ми були на межі, але викрутилися.
Якщо говорити про наш регіон, у нас так склалося, що проблем з киснем не було.
На відміну від інших - від тієї ж Одеської області.
Особливістю нашого регіону є те, що ми маємо завод "Азот",
який виробляє кисень. Тобто його не треба везти з іншої області.
Нині зростання точно загальмувалося і, можливо, є невеликий спад.
Але це не означає, що епідемія закінчилася.
У нашій області фактично поки що була лише одна хвиля.
А друга хвиля, як правило, протікає набагато важче, ніж перша.
Якщо говорити про тотальний локдаун, я не розумію, чому з 8-го січня?
Щоб погуляти на свята? А потім спокійно хворіти після свят, перебуваючи на карантині?
Я думаю, до Нового року треба вводити карантин.
Так, це захід не дуже приємний, народ його не розуміє, але якщо вводити - то вводити.